is it true that you do crazy things to
celebrate connecting with more people on
tick tock
yeah so every time uh we reach an
another
milestone another million uh i do these
things called millie mills
where i uh create like these outlandish
uh desserts or like crazy meals that you
know we all kind of dream about
having but not never actually tasted it
but it's been
it's been like it's been pretty crazy in
terms of how good
they have been you know a lot of people
are like i don't know if i would like
that amount of sugar
trust me it is unreal it is
it's so much i've ever actually said
that sentence in my entire existence
i think i'm like elf like like if
there's sugar i'm in
um yeah okay so you did this crazy thing
um on tick tock it's it's a death jump
on tick tock right is always
called yeah so basically um so you drop
a tissue from the top of the stairs
and you have to like run and try to
catch it before it touches the floor
so um everybody work out
yeah so i mean tic toc has all of these
kind of crazy challenges that you can
you know i'm saying do with the people
that you care about so you're not just
like
on netflix all day long playing video
games
it's just active things to do um
especially during these times right but
mine ended a little a little tricky you
know you know i i
i injured my knee a little bit it was a
little painful
i feel like all in you're one of those
people that play sports is like all in
oh oh it's all or nothing i'm
competitive oh man me too
oh it gets me in so much trouble
[Music]